Welcome back everyone this be my full Marvel
Shang Chi breakdown and Easter eggs video
for the entire movie.
Hopefully you've had a chance to see it.
It's out in theaters everywhere around the
world.
So make sure you do if you haven't yet.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos obviously
they tease a lot of big set up for Avengers
5 and what's going to be happening in the
future the MCU.
Separately from all the Kang multiverse war
stuff.
Careful for spoilers for the entire movie,
if you have not seen it.
Because we'll be talking about everything.
I also just did a video for the post credit
scene and the ending specifically, so I'll
add a link for that at the end of this and
in the description below.
But the movie timeline starts about a thousand
years ago when shang chi's mother lead telling
him the legend of the 10 rings as a child,
but his mother says the legend of how Wenwu
the Mandarin found the rings changes over
time with each new generation changing the
story a little some say he found them in a
crater after the crash to earth.
Some say he found them in a cave.
Those are all just references to the comic
book origin of the Makluan 10 rings of power
from the iron man comics, the Mandarin found
them in the Valley the sleeping Dragon in
ancient China when he came upon the makluans
crash spaceship the 10 rings were devices
that the makluans used to power their spaceship
which had crash to earth Fing fang Foom in
the Marvel universe was their navigator don't
explicitly call anyone from this alternate
dimension of towel low makluans.
But it seems like they will be the MCU version
of makluans.
But none of them are shapeshifting dragons
do have the great protector Dragon and it's
implied that some of their people like shang
chi's mother are descendents of the great
protector Dragon.
Like Peter Quill is a descendent of ego the
living planet has part celestials DNA during
the movie, shang chi's mother says that he
has the heart of their great dragon I think
that's both a metaphor and meant to be literal
like his mother is a descendent of the Dragon
in past that celestials DNA on to him in that's
why both shang chi in his mother can wield
the yellow energy of the great protector Dragon
because they share some of its DNA all talk
more about that in a second.
When we get to that part of the movie.
Because not everybody from that alternate
dimension can wield that special energy but
is shang chi's mother narrates the rest of
Wenwu's origin story you see him create the
10 rings organization a thousand years ago
conquer the known world later.
Wenwu says that he went by many names over
the years one of them was con, so it's him
saying that he was the real Genghis Khan,
he also clarifies that at no point during
history was he ever called the Mandarin by
anyone.
The Mandarin named itself was created by Aldrich
Killian name Trevor Slattery during the events
of Iron Man 3 he jokes that it's a chicken
dish is as they use that fake name in his
identity to make the Western nations terrified
of orange.
Like it turns into a big joke in the movie.
Because the Mandarin in the comics was this
big racist caricature meant to hype up yellow
peril when he was originally created also
connecting this back to iron man's origin
the first Iron Man movie later in the movie
when he's looking at these banks of monitors
you actually see footage from the first Iron
Man movie they included footage from
the film from the very beginning when they
were showing them off to the world holding
them hostage way they explain this is it was
Wenwu this whole time.
That was behind that he was after Tony Stark's
weapons.
So it's Marvel saying that he was responsible
for Tony Stark becoming Iron Man in the first
place during the montage of Wenwu conquering
the rest of the world you notice that he's
also attacking a Roman convoy stealing their
gold they explain over the centuries how he
slowly move the 10 rings out of the spotlight
inserted ruling from the shadows influencing
the course of human history by altering wars
the course of governments you see him attacking
Great Britain seeming like he affected the
British succession at some point you see is
meant influencing events in the middle eastern
conflicts closer to the present day in the
more recent wars then things really get started
during 1996 in that's around the period of
the first captain Marvel movie.
That's when they say that he had finally conquered
everything in the world.
There was to conquer remember, he's really
from the shadows though.
So even though hydra was incredibly active
inside shield shield was also very active
at this point to we found out later during
the ant-man movies that there were 10 rings
agents inside hydra.
So sort of like he's infiltrated all the groups
that have also themselves infiltrated regular
organizations like were the dudes, hiding
inside the group of dudes pretending to be
the other group of dudes to bring it back
around to Robert Downey Junior meme.
But around this period is
when he learns about the village of towel
low the power of the great protector Dragon
the special martial arts they practice the
soul leaders the dweller in darkness he says
is a place of great magical power.
But Michelle Yeoh's character whose lease
sister shang chi's mother says that the dweller
darkness has telepathically manipulated many
people over the many thousands of years that
is been trapped there to get them to come
to towel low to try and free it promising
all kinds of lies.
So it's kind of implied that that's initially
why he became so obsessed with the village
before he met Lee like the dweller darkness
could sense the power of the 10 rings and
knew they were powerful enough to free him.
So it planted the idea in Wenwu's head to
find the village they use the first trip in
the mid-90s to show you how the force may's
works is a magical force maze the just acts
as a protection a barrier to someone like
long or Doctor Strange or scarlet witch were
powerful enough in magic could probably fight
the effects of the forest shang chi's mother
Lee was one of the greatest warriors in the
village inactive sort of a first line of defense
outside the dimensional portal for anyone
who makes it past the forest this is where
we get to the whole Celeste Teal DNA Dragon
DNA of it all big Dragon energy.
So all the people of the village and towel
low are excellent fighters with Dragon level
weapons gifted to them by the great protector
Dragon made from parts of his body.
Like made from Dragon scales just things that
the Dragon sheds naturally they call it gives
from the Dragon.
But that's what it is and all the scales the
Dragon everything that falls off of it that
they turn into weapons is laced with it. Celestial energy
So that's how they are able to use the dragons
power when they wield the weapons notice during
the big third act fight scenes in the village
most of the people there in the village.
Even though their vast fighters can't wield
the same type of yellow energy that shang
chi in his mother wield she also tells Wenwu
that her special power when she's wielding
the 10 rings like shang chi does later in
the film.
Like when she's about to command male.
Wenwu until they get super turned on by their
fight they start flirting like flirt fighting
she tells him that the power is a gift from
the great protector Dragon.
But she loses the power seemingly when she
leaves the village to be with him.
I've said this before but I think all the
scenes here inclusions imply that she's a
direct descendent of the great protector Dragon
and the Dragon is just another celestial being.
Like ego the living planet, but from the dimension
of towel low like it's a Celeste Teal from
another dimension ego the living planet said
that he sired thousands of children over the
millennia Peter Quill just one of them.
And when Peter Quill is near ego.
He can use his full Celeste Teal abilities
forming matter around himself giving off celestial
energy blasts, but otherwise he just like
a normal person.
I think is the same deal with shang chi in
this also gets into what's really going on
with the 10 rings themselves, but Wenwu gets
his ass handed to him by Lee who clearly knows
all about the 10 rings and what they're really
supposed to be used for they make it seem
like Wenwu never fully understood the power
the 10 rings, so for a thousand years.
Even though they gave him immortality and
they seemingly made him very powerful he was
only using them at a fraction of their true
power.
Like during their whole first fight she's
kind of laughing at him the whole time will
she's embarrassing him taking the rings from
him.
As if he's a child and he's completely blown
away when he sees what she can do with the rings
Like I do know they were capable of that,
but he falls in love with her eventually takes
the rings off stops being the Mandarin is
also implied that he dissolved most of the
10 rings organization when they were together.
Like he doesn't have his army anymore when
shang chi and his sister Xialing are born
then later when he's a child his mother is
revenge, killed by the iron gain just another
random rival crime organization that Wenwu
had steamrolled when he was still active is
the Mandarin they show you that she's still
an amazing fighter.
She still managed to kill like 20 of their
people all of them on her own without any
weapons or any of her special Dragon celestial
power of energy tax but she dies from her
injuries in Wenwu get so angry and depressed
that he takes at the 10 rings of power again
rebuilds the 10 rings organization.
This is the point where shang chi flees to
San Francisco when he's about 14 years old.
Wenwu since him on his first mission to kill
the man that he believes is responsible for
Lee's death, shang chi can't bring himself
to kill someone like he doesn't want to turn
into a monster.
So he runs away to San Francisco where he
assumes the fake identity of Sean she meets
Katy as a freshman in high school later.
She makes fun of them for having such a weak
sauce fake identity.
Like your name is shang chi and you chose
shaun chi.
So all that was happening around the year
2010 when the events of Iron Man 2 were happening
That's when shang chi was 14 fleeing to America
just a place this in the timeline of the MCU
movies time jump to present day though and
if it wasn't clear the movie takes place a
good long while after avengers endgame, but
like I said in my post credit scene video
yesterday before the events of Spider-Man
far from home, and Spider-Man No Way Home.
Because of what's happening with long in the
sanctum during the movie when they go there
is not covered in snow Wong still looks exactly
like he did during avengers endgame.
Mostly none the worse for wear.
So this is all happening around the time falcon
and winter soldier's happening.
Maybe just a little bit later than that vitamin
far from home takes place about eight months
after avengers endgame.
If it wasn't clear Spider-Man No Way Home
will take place right after the end of Spider-Man
far from home.
So when this is happening in the movie Spider-Man
and Doctor Strange have not broken reality
yet, but you find out that shang chi is trying
to live as quietly as possible will not stick
out, hiding from his father they joke about
him and Katy parking cars not living up to
their potential the dinner with their friends
is just meant to set the joke in the mid credit
scene with Wong showing up to invite them
to join the avengers.
But the whole scene of Katy stealing the car
and then later with the bow and arrow helping
defeat the dweller darkness is just meant
to show you that she actually does have some
skills even though she's a normal person wasn't
clear she is not meant to secretly be someone else
She just a normal girl that shang chi met
and became friends with they imply during
the movie that there might be some romantic
connection between the two of them.
Like her grandmother jokes when the to you
getting married I made the comparison to Iron
Man and Pepper Potts in my last big video
is not quite like that.
Like she's not pining after him or anything
like that.
But I think slowly over the course of the
sequels.
Like by the end of the trilogy whenever that
winds up happening.
Then though finally get together the also
set up at karaoke joke with them doing karaoke
with Wong after he becomes one of the new
Avengers seeing Hotel California Katy also
says the Hotel California song is the one
she randomly started yelling at the high school
bully who was about to try and fight shang
chi and that's how they met for the first
time in high school, also during the first
karaoke session you notice this seeing a bunch
of Disney songs from classic Disney animated
movies, because this is a Disney movie shang
chi is a Marvel movie and Marvel's own by
Disney.
Wenwu sends razor fist to go pick up shang
chi and steal the pendant who is a comic book
character razor fist is a comic book character,
but is relatively minor one when he was a
child his mother told him that the pendant
would help him find his way home.
That's both a metaphor and meant to be literal.
Because Wenwu uses his and his sister's pendants
inside their mothers magical shrine to show
them the map of how to enter towel low and
literally go to her home where she's from
they never fully explain his mother's magic.
But, which is another type of magic like Doctor
Strange uses like Loki uses Agatha Harkness
scarlet witch everyone in the MCU has slightly
different kinds of magic that they use the
get into more the magic that the people of
towel low use during the sequels.
The big Avatar the last \f0 A\f1 ir\f0 b\f1
ender connection here to on the slide during
the movie the fighting style that's used by
Lee and her people of towel low is based more
on tai chi some of the Marvel people reference
air bending in Avatar the last Airbender specifically
because when shang chi in his mother use the
10 rings.
It kind of looks like their air bending and
when Mike and Br\f0 ya\f1 n and \f0 Sifu Kisu\f1
were creating the different bending styles
for Avatar the last Airbender the use
tai chi is the basis for how air bending looked
in, also during the movie.
Katy's little brother is played by Dallas
Liu the actor who's going to be playing
princes Zuko in the new Netflix Avatar
the last Airbender series also in the final
boss fight with the great protector Dragon
the dweller darkness in shang chi kind of
remind me visually of Aang and Zuko
learning the Dragon dance from the fire nation dragibs
So that to like there were a lot of references
to Avatar the last Airbender during the movie.
Some of that was on purpose, shang chi, winds
up kicking their asses on the bus sort of
outing himself is really badass martial artist
the person filming the fight and other big
Easter a cameo scene here with his phone uploads
it to YouTube later is your boy clev
he the same street vendor dude from Spider-Man
homecoming is meant to be the exact same character.
Just in San Francisco now, there's even this
funny media tie-in fake wiki that they created
for the character specifically for the purposes
of the movie.
He films the fight comments on it in a funny
way, and then upload to do you to where goes viral
So now the whole world knows who shang chi is.
Even though they don't know his name they
wind up calling him busboy they might wind
up paying this joke off during the next avengers
film were some of the other avengers characters
like oh hey it's busboy I saw your video on
YouTube but because this is all happening
in San Francisco the producers also said they
thought about having cameo scenes from the
ant-man the wasp characters like Jimmy Woo
Scott laying the others, but they thought
that if they got to crazy with the cameos.
It would detract too much take too much focus
away from shang chi story in the movie, so
that's why they kept the cameos relatively
light and there is no Stanley cameo because
he passed away may he rest in peace and Marvel
said they're not gonna be doing Stanley cameos.
With special effects or anything like that,
during this bus fight scene to if you think
it feels a lot like a Jackie Chan type of
fight scene when he takes his jacket off and
uses it to fight the dude then puts it back
on it starts fighting again that is a Jackie
Chan move is because the fight choreographer
on the movie is one of Jackie chance Todd
dudes his name was Brad Allen he was super
bad ass.
But he wound up passing away after they finish
the movie, so that's why there was the dedication
to him during the credits also of your big
aficionado of martial arts films a grumpy
old man and towel low who kept yelling at
Katy is played by Eun Waugh who did stones
on the classic Bruce Lee films like enter
the Dragon in a billion other Jackie Chan movies
But, shang chi, winds up getting a letter
from his sister or he thinks is from his sister
and it's got the same drawing depicting of
the great protector Dragon that his mother
made for him as an origami figure as a child
later he finds out that this was just a trick that
Wenwu pulled to get them in the same place
where he can round them up together.
Macau, but they go to Macau and find out that
his sister fled home.
When she turns 16 years old after shang chi
had fled to America.
Only she went to Macau and set the underground
fighting ring turning into this big business
which is meant to foreshadow her taking control
of the 10 rings organization after their father
dies when they mean John John, who also shows
up in the post credit scene.
Later he explains how the fighting ring works
to them.
They pass a bunch of low-level fights in one
of them is an extremist soldier who still
alive after the events of Iron Man three.
Which kind of foreshadows the eventual Trevor
reveal more iron man three Easter eggs in
the way they connected to the previous Mandarin
stuff in the MCU.
But then they show you wrong fighting the
abomination in the main ring Mortal Kombat
style and as cool as this is the craziest
thing here is that Wong acts like he's been
helping to train the abomination like their
burrows and he's been helping them get better
maybe Wong is also been using this to earn
some sandwich money because they say that
shang chi is going to earn a ton of money
when he fights in the ring they had the big
joke about Katy betting against him and winning
a ton of money one uses his portals to cause
abomination to punch himself knocking himself
out cold.
They turn it into a big joke with a ton of
dudes having to come drag him out of the ring
because he so big and heavy then later they
show the two of them chatting in the locker room
Like they're old mates is that they do this
kind of thing on the regular Wong opens up
a portal to a special containment self the
looks a lot like the one they made for the
whole during the first avengers movie is implied
the facility where this is is super high-tech
like this is the raft.
Even though they never fully explain what's
going on with this later the producer said
this is just the beginning for the abomination
they'll be more story for him and Marvel phase 4
Kevin Feige has already confirmed that he's
going to show up during the she hulk series
Mark Ruffalo is also coming back during that
it is in the mid credit scene as well with
diesel pay this scene off during she hulk
next year and it'll be connected to what Val
is doing putting together her team of thunderbolts
and dark avengers in the MCU.
But, Val herself does not appear in is not
referenced anywhere in the movie, shang chi,
winds up having to fight his sister who knocks
him out because he refuses to fight her and
then they reconnect learning that there follows
behind everything death dealer his men come
to take her pendant to their that really badass
scaffolding fight scene in the whole thing
with death dealer in the movie, so many people
were curious about this when the trailers
got out kind of winds up being an overhyped
trailer villain.
He just a mid-level bosses meant to be bad
ass and they kill him off superquick at the
end of the movie getting his soul sucked out.
If you're confused about what was going on
with his character he's not meant to secretly
be someone else.
He just a random badass that they kill off
superquick they go back to Wenwu's fortress
he explains how he thinks their mother has
been speaking to him through the 10 rings
really is the dweller in darkness just gas
lighting him, they reveal the magical map
using the pendants and then reveal what happened
to Trevor Slattery so welcome back Ben Kingsley
I think we all assume that there will be some
sort of cameo scene a reference to him in
the movie, so this wasn't a huge surprise
they claim that after the events of the iron
man three one-shot all hail the king.
Wenwu had his men bust Trevor out and when
they were about to execute him.
He started monologue and it made the men laugh
so much that Wenwu just kept him around as
a court jester to amuse them Morris the magical
creature from towel low is someone who.
Wenwu found on one of his subsequent missions
in the forest trying to find an entrance to
the village Morris also explains that he's
so old he grew up with shang chi's mother
he helps them navigate the maze naturally
using his magic they escape the compound using
razor fist electric BMW if it wasn't clear
this is also meant to be a joke paying off
the referenced earlier in the movie when Katy
told the story of how she met shang chi for
the first time.
There was the bully who she had to sing Hotel
California to stop, but she said later that
they stole his car and took it on a joy ride.
So this is them just doing the same thing
to razor fist.
They do have a bunch of funny Trevor scenes
with them talking about being inspired about
the original planet of the apes movie.
Because he thought the apes were real, then
they show you them traveling through the wormhole
between dimensions.
That's what's happening when they go to the
waterfall cave.
It looks very similar to the effect when Doctor
Strange is traveling through different dimensions
and they explained that the village is just
one point where there dimensions connect they're
here to protect their dimension as well as
the main MCU dimension from the dweller darkness
in the soul eaters they been here for about
4000 years.
But the people of their dimension have a culture
this way more ancient than human culture Michelle
Yeoh's character talks about the grand cities
that they have that far surpass anything in
the main MCU dimension.
I think that's all just meant to be set up
for this equals like we'll see some of those
other cities in this other dimension during
shang chi to she explains the history of her
people and how the dweller darkness came from
you yet another dimension into theirs and
started sucking everyone souls until the great
protector Dragon appeared to help in trap
behind the special Dragon scale gate in the
comics, the dweller darkness is one of Marvel's fear lords
It's kind of like the Marvel comic book version
of Cthulhu it comes from a dimension called
Evergreen and the fear lords or cosmic beings
that feed on people's fears, but I was he
they change their little bit for the movie
and it just eats people souls in the MCU they
just wanted to be like another extradimensional
creature on par with someone like dormammu
someone who could become super powerful images
continues to suck more souls I know the visualization
of its energy looks kind of purple like dormammu's
energy or Agatha Harkness is purple magic
she does feed on other people's magic like
scarlet witch.
But I think this is more of a coincidence
that they could always turn into a bigger
connection in future Marvel movies if they
want shang chi fights Wenwu to stop him from
opening the gate the rest of the way while
the soul eaters start slipping through powering
up the dweller darkness with solar energy
so that he can break through the rest the
gate the great protector Dragon comes out
of hibernation under the lake to help them
and they have a very Luke Skywalker versus
Darth Vader return of the Jedi type of arc
here where they do fight each other.
But eventually Wenwu comes to his senses realizes
he loves his children and sacrifices himself
Darth Vader style to save shang chi from the
dweller darkness getting his soul sucked out
of the process.
So RIP, evil Popa bless he passes the 10 rings,
the shang chi who uses them the same way his
mother did earlier go to Dragon Ball style
with their yellow Dragon celestial energy.
Like I said earlier I think this is just meant
to be similar to the way Peter Quill's celestial
powers work in earlier in the movie Michelle
Yeoh's character clearly implies that the
10 rings came from their dimension and not
from the main MCU dimension.
Like these rings were made by the MCU version
of the makluans.
But there combining that with the idea the
celestial Dragon here.
And these people's culture and that's why
shang chi and his mother are able to wield
the 10 rings to their full power and how is
able to Dragon Ball command may the dweller
darkness with that giant finishing move attack.
Like I said, you notice the other people in
the village can't wield this energy that's
why think that only some of these people like
shang chi's mother in shang chi are direct
descendents of the great protector Dragon
my early theory is that the play it like the
Thor movies with his powers like the Thor
movies of all the way Thor used his powers
and how they explain them in the MCU will
probably eventually find out that he doesn't
need the 10 rings to wield that Dragon energy
as his mother said he has the heart of the
great dragon will probably be able to generate
the power from himself.
Katy winds up helping them defeat the dweller
darkness using the Dragon arrow and then they
go back to San Francisco is also implied that
they let Trevor go free when they went back.
Like he just free on earth now his sister,
winds up going back to China their fathers
compound to take over the 10 rings and then
during the mid credit scene Wong shows up again
They pay out that joke from the beginning
of the movie how neither one of them were
living up to their potential.
I love the whole vibe of this scene to like
longer shows up.
Like it's no big deal.
Interrupting everyone's dinner and steals
one of the drink.
Like all right, let's go Wong Coulson avengers
Sue meeting inside the sanctum avengers endgame
style using that same technology they discuss
the 10 rings study them with the Holt who's
completely change back into banner now his
arm still a gimpy and that slaying is permanently
damage from the infinity gauntlet, but otherwise.
He seems fine.
He seems like he's in good spirits Captain
Marvel has the exact same suit from avengers endgame
But she's let her hair grown out again.
That's why say it's been several months since
avengers endgame Wong says the doctor Strange
and the other sorcerers and Kamar Taj felt
it when shang chi use the 10 rings to defeat
the dweller darkness they felt it in another
dimension, they reveal that their far older
than anything that Doctor Strange has records
of in the sanctum's but that's more of a reference
to them being created many thousands of years
ago in a different dimension of towel allow
that's why they have no record of them in
the sanctum is because most of the records
only cover things from the main MCU dimension,
but they're broadcasting a special signal
at the atomic level cosmic pager like Captain
Marvel's cosmic pager and make it sound like
a sending a signal to whoever created the
rings like another cosmic being from the towel
allow dimension in the reason why a lot of
people are talking about galactus is because
the way galactus explained in the Marvel universe.
He's a character who came from a previous
version of the universe.
So is not from the main MCU universe.
He's from another universe.
Technically, but they'll get into this more
during shang chi to in the sequel and then Avengers 5
Like this whole scene is meant to set up the
next big Avengers movie.
Because Wong basically says welcome to the
team welcome to the avengers Sue however the
mystery signal is broadcasting two is meant
to be an Avengers level threat and I don't
think it has anything to do with the Kang
multiversal war like Kang did not create the
rings of power.
But connecting things back to Loki when you
talk about the next big Avengers level team
up the Kang multiverse war.
They'll just be another thing that shang chi
has in common with the other avengers characters
like what ties them together.
There's something that threatens the dimension
where my mother comes from.
And our main dimension to the payoff the karaoke
joke from earlier in the movie with long going
with them to sing Hotel California also paying
off the Hotel California reference from earlier
in the movie.
The post credit scene is just setting up Xialing
is the leader of the new 10 rings organization,
she changes the logo to read now allows women
assassins to fight for them black widow style
in the tag reads the 10 rings will return
this means in the sequel yes obviously, but
they'll also show up before that to and I
think we'll see them all over the place eventually
in the MCU movies Disney plus series.
This could also be them setting up a shang
chi spinoff Disney plus series.
Just about the 10 rings like a 10 rings TV
show.
I did a much bigger video on the post credit
scenes with even more Easter egg.
So a link that blown the description and at
the end of this.
But he did spot any other big Easter eggs
or references during the movie that I didn't
talk about during the video just right them
blown the comments.
I tried to cover all the really really biggest
stuff I am working on some more videos about
the abomination in Avengers five stuff though
should post the next couple of days, so make
sure you have alerts enabled so you don't
miss that my big Marvel what if episode 5
video will also post Wednesday just like normal
every week everyone click here for my full
shang chi post credit scene video and click
here for my full Spider-Man No Way Home trailer video
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see in the next video!